depuis l'enlèvement samedi dernier de 17
missionnaire parmi eux un canadien et
cinq enfants les ravisseurs multiplie
les démonstrations de force réaffirmant
sur les réseaux sociaux leur intention
d'exécuter des otages si la rançon de 17
millions de dollars n'est pas payé est
ce qu'il faut c'est
parce qu'il ya plusieurs personnes
plusieurs haïtiens haïtiennes qui a été
agréé qui
de la lancer des menaces qu'ottawa prend
très au sérieux affaire mondiale canada
nous informe que l'otage canadien
dénommé originaire de l'ontario et que
les agents consulaires sont en contact
avec sa famille à la maison blanche on
souhaite mettre un frein la
prolifération des gangs criminels en
haïti
nous voulons renforcer la capacité de la
police haïtienne de lutter contre les
gangs armés la secrétaire de presse
adjointe admet que c'est un travail
difficile et de longue haleine un
travail d'autant plus ardu qui hier le
directeur général de la police à
démissionner il est membre du corps mais
qui les ont enlevés
contrôler toute la commune où ils sont
entrés de pv ce qui veut dire qu'en fait
il ya des possibilités pour que ces
missionnaires ne sont pas gardés en un
seul endroit le groupe criminel 400 maoz
au contrôle près de la moitié de la
région métropolitaine de port au prince
un territoire de plus de 1900 kilomètres
carrés un groupe armé jusqu'aux dents et
qui sèment la terreur en toute impunité
la majorité des hommes à feu qui
circulent sur lequel israéliens
reviennent d'espagne ni d'amis face à
l'horreur les familles des otages ont
adressé une lettre aux ravisseurs
une lettre qui décrit leur impuissance
leur tristesse est dans laquelle dix
priait pour les otages ainsi que leurs
ravisseurs
en haïti l'insécurité rampante attise la
colère de la rue
il n'y a pas d'essence et nos enfants
enfin totalité mais rien n'avance les
autorités nous prennent en otages dit
cet autre haïtien il n'y a pas d'essence
depuis trois jours les accusations de
corruption portées contre deux hauts
fonctionnaires
l'inflation et l'insécurité planches ou
encore une fois à haïti dans une spirale
de violence ici as mitraillette radio
canada montréal